good morning everyone I'm Michelle
Miller and we're in the CBS this morning
greenroom with the sisters of Sandra
bland in July of 2015
Sandra bland was arrested after a minor
traffic violation in Prairie View Texas
three days later the 28 year old was
found hanging in a jail cell
her death was ruled a suicide the
questions surrounding the circumstances
and disturbing video of her arrest
sparked allegations of a racially
motivated murder and nationwide protests
a new HBO documentary say her name the
life and death of Sandra bland examines
blends activism and her family's battle
for answers about her time in custody
we're joined now by bland Sisters Shanti
Needham and Sharon Cooper we thank you
both for being here with us thank you
for having us
when this took place back in 2015 I
think what was so shocking was to see a
woman literally being dragged out of a
car there have been lots of attention
what was taking place with
african-american men and and the traffic
stops but to see a woman treated in this
way for some people was really just so
disturbing people don't know who Sandra
bland was and I want you to explain to
me she had everything going for her at
this particular point in her life she
had gotten a new job she was excited
about this and then she stopped for
giving a turn mm-hmm
I think I think you raised a really good
point i think that we have shined a
light so traditionally on black men and
boys on what happens to them
and traffic stops and on what I think
Sandra's story did was it amplified the
issue of police brutality in terms of
the interaction between law enforcement
and those in the black community I think
that what you see in Sandy's story to
your point she had her whole life of had
ahead of her was very involved and
engaged in her life and the lack of a
law enforcement official to de-escalate
a situation and really stand by there
to protect and serve can cause a seismic
shift in one's life to the point where
it becomes fatal I know this was a woman
who many people say should never have
gone to jail absolutely for traffic stop
take us through what exactly happened
here she was she had made a turn not a
turn she she had failed to signal to
change lanes but what does the
documentary tell us that we don't know
about what took place I think what the
documentary takes you through is what
transpired within that three day period
and quite frankly our interest in trying
to piece together what happened because
we weren't there we weren't there
viewers weren't there with her the
jailers and also to the police officer
who actually delivered her to the jail
right and so what you'll see there is
that there are why we have those
questions is that what we were initially
told at the time that we had
conversations what would control what we
were told was that when you come to
Texas you'll be able to definitively see
that she contributed to her own death
you'll be able to see that this is the
reason why we believe that she committed
suicide
there will be evidentiary proof of that
to which there was none so to that in
the film takes you through a look of the
questions that we have the lingering
questions that we have but what it also
does - is that it humanize 'as someone
who beyond the headlines takes you into
who she was as a person takes you into
her life as a daughter as a sister as an
aunt as a friend as a sorority sister to
many who loved and cared about her and
we here at first person through sandy
speaks I mean the the use of this form
of expression is just tell us more about
that shot I think she was just fed up
with all of those social injustice that
were going on just around the world
period and so she decided one day that
she would use her voice to speak on it
she was an activist yeah and she really
felt committed to
passionate to bringing like some social
understanding between you know race
relations into the floor front she
wasn't a racist wait I think people have
it misconstrued she wanted to unite
everyone because she everyone needed to
be on one Accord period and that's all
she wanted and also too I think the
videos them the first one for my two
sons which are they were young
african-american boys at the time and
with so much going on around with black
men I think she wanted to focus on them
because as she said in her video but
young people are forgotten at some point
and she just wanted to focus and bring
those young people thoughts to the
forefront this is a documentary which
doesn't just give you voice the family
voice it gives a voice to the DA gives a
voice to several other people in law
enforcement talk about why the
filmmakers seem to draw a pretty
straight narrow line down the middle and
on their quest to tell the story well we
talked about the need for conversation
and community building right that is
what we see going on in these situations
where police encounters returning fatal
there is an immense amount of
miscommunication misunderstanding and so
what we wanted to do was avoid that in
in sharing in this film what our
experience was like we think it's
equally important to shine a light on
what the Texas officials experience was
like and what they what they experienced
and so I think that it creates for a
more balanced narrative if you will I
think what it does is it seeks to answer
a lot of the questions that people had
seeks to take viewers into the minds and
into the jail and into the courtroom
quite frankly to see some of the
conversations that were going on and so
I think that that was the intent with
the filmmakers was try to present a
holistic view it also gives the family
because the family did receive a
settlement
from the county but more so there were
some stipulations with what you wanted
to see happen within the police
department absolutely did you get what
you asked for what did you ask for and
did you get what you asked for
so with regard to this settlement right
my mom did noncompensatory piece was
what she was most passionate about thing
out of my right so that hopefully no
other family could possibly would have
to endure what we have so Diaz go into
the escalation training which they kind
of like slid through the crack and have
not done that but they do have the wands
where they have to scan the inmates and
that's the biggest thing the biggest
thing for us was gee escalation training
what what the Sandra bland Act does do
in its current state is there is a
mental health component of it which we
do think is equally important if you
come into a state or federal facility
you are in there custodial care and it's
their responsibility to give you the
appropriate care based off of the
information that you provide to them at
that time of intake right so there's
that component of it which is important
to us I think ultimately what we want to
share with people is that legislation is
something that it's a marathon it's not
a sprint and we learned that through
this process and what we'll continue to
do not just on behalf of Sandy but the
many others who have been impacted by a
tragedy such as this is to really really
focus on the need for de-escalation
training unconscious and conscious bias
by his training to try to just continue
that conversation around closing that
gap between law enforcement and people
of color in their communities for a lot
of people though it was the the
effective Bryan and Cena the trooper who
pulled her over didn't pull a trigger in
in many people's minds that's why he
didn't like Hill her out right I mean in
many scenes you see you know you see the
video of someone shooting
and killing someone that they pull over
this isn't what happened here he is no
longer with law enforcement in Texas and
in fact cannot any longer be a part of
any form of law enforcement in Texas and
Texas where what do we know about him we
don't know much and what I will tell you
is this you make a great point that
while he didn't pull the trigger he was
one who was in a position of power and
the misuse of your power is equivalent
to me to pulling a trigger so we don't
know where he is he's virtually gone
under the radar
I would imagine his whether or not he's
having a tough time in life as far as
I'm concerned is not a concern to us at
all I think that there is an immense
amount of accountability that you have
to take for changing the course of
someone's life
which he has not done to this day and so
I do know that the filmmakers sought him
out to try to get his side of the story
as well to which they were not
successful do you think as a community
as a nation we're suffering from outrage
fatigue yes I do absolutely there is a
level of numbness that transpires when
you're seeing some of the same stories
over and over again we saw even this
week that there are new families
unfortunately who will be joining what
we call this fraternity and sorority
that no one should be a part of which is
you know this burgundy and social
justice narrative around disparate
treatment between law enforcement and
people in black and brown communities
and what we're seeing a lot on our TV
screen is what's happening within black
community so what that turns into
sometimes is that there may be a level
of concern that people don't care or
people aren't paying attention but those
in those marginalized communities who
are being impacted they're speaking of
the burden and the onus now is on those
who are in positions of power who sit in
a level of privilege either from a race
gender or socioeconomic status where
this may not be impacting them to really
amplify their voice and utilize their
platform to bring attention to these
issues yeah you really want them to see
this documentary is their last question
is there
the question that we don't answer but I
do want to say this we need
accountability we really need
accountability all across the globe I
think if the police start being held
accountable for their actions then the
citizens and of the world will begin to
start trusting law enforcement officials
just a little bit but if they continue
on being slapped on the wrist if I may
say I don't think we'll ever be able to
get to a place of equality
well Shantae needle sharing we really
appreciate you being here and we go we
want to tell everyone that the name of
this this documentary is say her name
and they say it they say it loudly say
her name the life and death of Sandra
bland Sandra bland it premieres Monday
December 3rd at 10:00 p.m. Eastern on
HBO